skeptics may scoff through the existence
of ESP and other paranormal powers but
the US government hasn't always been so
sure in fact millions of dollars have
been spent over several decades to find
out if such human capabilities actually
exists that pursuit is the subject of
the new book phenomena the secret
history of the US government's
investigations into extrasensory
perception perception and psychokinesis
were joined by Annie Jacobsen author and
a 2016 Pulitzer Prize finalist in
history hi Annie
I think we were I think a lot of us are
shocked the government actually spent
money looking at this but you also point
out very quickly in the 1975 the CIA
concluded that a large body of reliable
evidence exists to the inescapable
conclusion that ESP does exist I mean
it's this astonishing conclusion to draw
and it's created an enormous
battleground for decades between the CIA
and the Defense Department as they you
know inquire into this area that has so
long been associated with the
supernatural with magic and here we are
advanced science looking at it how did
the US government first get involved or
interested in this kind of phenomena
well like so many Defense Department
programs it all leads back to the Nazis
and at the end of the war military
intelligence collected a cache of Nazi
documents called das on an Arab a and
that was Heinrich Himmler's suit you
know science into this extra sensory
perception psychokinesis we got half the
Russians got the other half and that led
to what we know now is the psychic arms
race Wow
there was always a battle though within
the intelligence community was there
wasn't there about whether this was
legitimate always a battle I mean you
have skeptics on the one hand who say
this does not pass scientific method
muster the experiments are not
repeatable it's pseudoscience you have
others who are in the work who insist
based on that quote you said and this
some extraordinary success stories
locating hostages locating lost weapons
downed aircraft so this debate
science versus the supernatural has been
going on for decades and it's infinitely
interesting beyond ESP you talk about
something called remote viewing what
exactly is that and what other kinds of
phenomena was the government interested
in pursuing well it's a great point you
bring up remote viewing is essentially
ESP under a different name and it was
done the CIA created that term in the
70s to try to de stigmatize this idea of
extrasensory perception yeah even they
even worked with people like uri geller
who's a name i think some of us know in
this in this research didn't they Geller
was a CIA asset we know that from the
documents I interviewed his handlers I
interviewed Geller himself the reason he
left the program was he was allegedly
also working for Mossad and that has
become a great mystery over the decades
we talked about did various programs
that have been Declassified you talked
about one called Project Sun streaked
tell us what that is
Sun streaked again one of the names for
this series of very similar programs
that dealt with these same basic issues
of can you see things far away well
through a means other than the five
senses through the sixth sense so to
speak it was a special access program
which means that have extraordinary
classification measures they kept
changing the names of the programs to
try to keep the Russians and the Chinese
from knowing what we were doing did they
actually try to train people to be
psychic they did at the Defense
Department and that's where real grave
problems arose the CIA's position was
this is individualistic this is a
biological phenomena it's physiological
and they sought to investigate think of
the the analogy of like I can't sing in
the shower think what Mozart does that's
how the CIA saw psychic where are we now
with these types of programs we're back
in the same place we were in the 70s
except for we have advanced technology
brought into the mix now so you have the
Defense Department working on programs
but bringing in you know computer
technologists neurobiology fascinating
totally riveting the book is phenomena
annie jacobson thanks so much for being
with us thanks Annie